-Welcome to "The Tonight Show."
-Oh, my God.
-I'm very happy you're here.
-Me too.
-Yeah.
-Yeah!
-I -- You know, I --
I'm so excited that you're here,
because I will tell you this.
I held you as a baby.
-You -- You held me?
-Yeah, I held you.
-As a baby?
-As a baby,
I held you like this.
-Crazy!
-I met you with your parents --
Uma Thurman, Ethan Hawke.
-Yeah, those are them.
-Yeah, and I --
And I held you --
I think it was in Rhinebeck
at someone's house,
and I was holding you.
I think my mother
even held you, as well.
-Wow. See?
That's just so crazy.
It's like -- I feel like
most people come here
on the first time,
and they get to, like,
tell you their life story.
-I raised you.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
You raised me, yeah.
[ Overlapping dialogue ]
-Second time we're meeting.
"Tell me about your life." Yeah.
But I do remember your par--
You were reading "Ferdinand."
-"Ferdinand the Bull."
-Was the book you were reading.
-I love that book.
-And I go,
"Oh, I don't know that book,"
and your parents were like --
Your mom was like,
"You don't know 'Ferdinand'?"
-I mean, it's a classic.
-I know, but I was 20-something.
I didn't read kids' books.
-That's not what you read
on your day-to-day...?
-No, I was reading Judy Blume
at the time.
But I was like, "Okay."
And they were so nice.
And I was like,
"What a cute baby."
And then just to watch your
career just rise right now.
It's just awesome.
Congratulations on everything.
I'm so proud of you.
-Aww. Thank you so much.
-You put the work in, bud.
-Thank you so much.
I mean, I don't know about that.
-Yeah, you did.
-But, um, no, I mean,
it's -- it's so awesome.
I was -- I called my mom
to ask for advice today
about coming in to talk to you.
-Yeah.
-Because that's what I do.
I get to ask for advice.
It's a big luxury of mine.
-Yeah.
-And we just got into
talking about, um,
like the Supreme Court ruling...
-Yeah.
-...and this essay
that my mom wrote, like,
a couple months ago
when they were putting these
further restrictions
on abortion access,
and it was sort of
preceding this whole thing.
And my mom wrote this really
beautiful essay about,
uh, her abortion that she got
when she was really young
and about how
if she hadn't have had it,
she wouldn't have become
the person that she'd become
and I wouldn't exist and how
both of my parents' lives
would've been totally derailed
if she hadn't had access to safe
and legal healthcare --
fundamental healthcare.
And I -- Of course,
like, wealthy people
will always be able
to get abortions,
but so many people, because
of this ruling this, like, week
will not only not be able
to pursue their dreams,
but actually lose their lives
and be unsafe, and, um --
I just wanted to say that,
like, you know,
[Bleep] the Supreme Court.
-Yeah, okay, yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
You can absolutely say that.
-Yeah, but we're going
to keep fighting this.
I can say
"[Bleep] the Supreme Court"?
-Yeah.
-[Bleep] the Supreme Court.
Yeah. Rock on.
And we're gonna keep --
But we're gonna keep fighting.
And we're gonna win
like our grandmothers did.
So I think that's good.
-Yeah. I'm happy
you said that message.
I appreciate you.
Thank you for saying that.
Thank you for saying
that message.
Thank you.
-Thank you.
-I wanted to talk about --
I know your parents
are very proud of you.
-I hope so.
-Every time they're on the show,
they talk about you.
-You always bring me up.
They're annoyed about it.
They're like,
"I want to talk about me."
-No, they don't. No.
But I thought it was funny.
I looked at your Instagram bio.
This is @maya-hawke.
And under here it says
"Tony Hawk's daughter."
So your dad
must really love that.
-I don't know why it's funny,
but it makes me laugh.
-No, it made me laugh, too.
I got it.
'Cause you're not
Tony Hawk's daughter.
-No. I know!
-But you're a great actor,
and I talked to your --
I think it was your dad
or your mom
last time they were on,
and I was talking about
how proud they were.
It was your dad.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Your dad saw you perform.
-Oh.
Oh, as a backup singer
for my brother?
-Yes.
-Yeah, that was
his favorite moment.
-He got weepy. He got weepy.
And he goes, "I'm just
so proud of my kids."
-I think he likes seeing
my ego settle in, you know?
Stand behind my brothers
a little bit.
-Exactly. But you have a song
that's released right now
out at midnight, tonight.
-Yeah!
-Congratulations. It's out.
-Thank you.
-You can --
Now, I'm gonna -- Hopefully --
"Thérèse" I think
is how it's pronounced.
-Yeah.
-But it's spelled T-H-E-R-E-S-E.
-Yeah, it has two little guys
on it, too, little French guys.
-Yes. "Thérèse."
-"Thérèse."
-Yeah.
-And what does --
What does that mean?
-It's the name of a --
There's a painting at the Met,
and it's called
"Thérèse Dreaming."
And it's the name
of the girl in the painting,
and it's a song about
the girl in the painting
who, in my head, is me.
So, yeah.
-I love that you made it.
You were explaining it to me.
You were like, "Well, I'm lucky
I'm acting, which is awesome."
But when you're acting, there's
also a lot of time that you're
just kind of waiting around for
lights or something to happen.
You're like, "I'm not gonna
waste any time, man.
I'm Maya Hawke.
I'm ready to go."
-Where's a napkin?
Where's the back of my sides?
-"Let's write something."
And you have an album...
-Yeah.
--...coming out. I'm gonna --
-I've never seen that.
-I know I'm about to show you
for the first time.
This is your real --
This is your vinyl.
-We got it made especially
for you -- an early release.
Oh, it's so cool!
It's see-through?!
-Oh, yeah.
-Oh! Look at that.
I can see you through it.
-Is that rad?
Is that the coolest?
-Aah! That's so rad!
-"Moss."
"Moss" is the name of the album.
-Be careful. I'm --
-Yeah, be careful.
Yeah, of course.
-But that's the first time
I've -- That's the first one.
We got it pressed for you.
-You -- You -- This is it.
-Yeah.
-Are you excited?
-Yeah!
-Yeah, alright, good.
When does this come out?
Do we know?
-Uh, it comes out in September.
-September.
-Yeah, back-to-school record
is kind of the premise.
-It's a back-to-school record.
It's called "Moss."
It's Maya Hawke.
I want to talk to you
about "Stranger Things."
-That's what I want
to talk about.
-It's the biggest show
in the world.
-Yeah. It's big.
-It's giant. It is.
It's number one on Netflix in
over 80 countries, by the way.
-That's crazy.
-Yeah, isn't that wild?
-Yeah.
-It's the biggest thing ever.
You're fantastic in it.
-Thank you!
-Volume 2 comes out July 1st.
-Yeah.
-This Friday.
-Yeah!
-Yeah, exactly.
Now, what can you say
about these episodes?
Anything -- No spoilers, right?
-Well, the thing is, we filmed
them a long time ago now.
It takes a long time to --
put it together.
-Sure.
-And so, I know --
I know that I know what happens.
-Mm-hmm.
-But can I tell --
I don't remember exactly.
[ Laughter ]
I -- I haven't seen them yet.
And I don't remember exactly,
but that's why I'm excited
'cause I'm so excited
to just see how it all wraps up.
-Those guys are pretty amazing,
those Duffer brothers.
-They're so smart.
They're such good writers.
I don't know if you've noticed
that I'm talking like
Phoebe Buffay on Adderall.
Like, I do this really
fast-talking thing.
But they noticed
when I come on set --
I don't do it all the time
with my friends,
but when I get nervous,
it, like, all --
And so they noticed that I do
that 'cause I was nervous on set
and then they wrote me
so much dialogue this season.
I know if you noticed,
but I have these giant page-long
monologues, and they're like,
"No, do, don't worry.
You'll just do it in 2 minutes.
You'll do it real fast."
-But a normal actor
would read this,
it'll take them 30 minutes.
Maya's gonna nail this
in 2 seconds, yeah.
-One breath. Brrr!
-Brrr! Yeah.
You're so fun and so good.
I love your character.
And you just --
You fit right in because --
Was it last season was the first
season you debuted, right?
-Yeah.
-And I was like,
"Oh, my gosh.
It's Maya. I love you."
-"I held that baby!"
"I held that baby!"
-"That's my girl." Yeah.
-She likes "Ferdinand the Bull"!
-Yes! Of course!
And you just nailed it.
Alright.
So get ready. July 1st.
This is volume 2, season 4.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Maya Hawke in season 4 of
"Stranger Things." Take a look.
♪♪
-And then Vickie laughed.
And it wasn't like a cheap
fake laugh, either.
It was like --
It was a real, genuine laugh.
-Of course she laughed, Robin.
It's my Muppet joke.
It's hilarious.
-My point is
that Vickie laughed
and everything was just,
like -- it was perfect.
-But?
-But I'm having this problem,
where it's like
I should stop talking.
I have said everything
I need to say.
But then I guess I get nervous,
and the words,
they just --
they keep spilling out.
And it's like my -- my brain
is moving faster than my mouth,
or -- or rather m-my mouth
is moving faster than my brain,
and it's like I'm digging
this hole for myself,
and I want to stop digging
and I'm trying to stop digging,
but I can't -- and I'm doing it
right now, aren't I?
-Yeah, you are.
-[ Sighs ]
-Yeah, that's how you do it.
Maya Hawke, everybody!
Season 4, volume 2
of "Stranger Things"
premiers July 1st on Netflix.
And Maya's new album, "Moss,"
is out September 23rd!
You can preorder it now.